former WWE wrestler China's rep tells et
there was a plan in place for a
televised intervention scheduled within
a week of when the reality star and
athlete died from a believed drug
overdose
according to her rep the TV show
intervention was quickly planning it
quote we were going to document her
intervention anyways because we are in
the middle of filming a documentary on
her life already titled the
reconstruction of China the plans are to
release it in 2017 the plan was to ask
China's pals a Billy Gunn Mick Foley and
Stone Cold Steve Austin to participate
but they did not have the chance to
reach out to the wrestlers before
China's death
China's rep believed she was misusing
prescription medication saying quote the
intervention was for the pills to get
her under watch two weeks ago I begged
her to get under control and she knew
she knew she had a problem we talked
about it I believed as she was ready to
get help and that's why we were planning
an intervention now China's wrapped lzt
her friends and family are focusing on a
memorial for the late star